hey what's going on everybody before I
get started I want to announce the new
giveaway that I'm going to be doing this
month this one's a little bit different
though this month I'm going to be giving
away two different things on the same
day I have the world of Ice and Fire
book and I also have the Game of Thrones
trivia game and two winners are going to
be picked this time the first person
that is randomly selected will get to
pick which one day one and the second
name that is randomly selected will get
the other prize just go down to the
description and click on that link and
follow those steps that way your name is
entered for the giveaway and also added
a few new ways to enter that way you
could possibly have more chances to win
so good luck to everybody that
participates now let's get started with
today's news and this is going to be a
spoiler filled video but the first thing
I want to discuss is the short clip that
was actually released so check this out
first
[Music]
it appears to be the Valyrian steel
sword Oathkeeper the sword that Tywin
had made from Ned Stark's sword ice
which Thailand later gave to his son
Jaime then Jaime later gave to Brienne
of Tarth why do you think they released
this clip do you think there is any
significance to this I think there is
and I'm assuming that something is
probably going to happen to this sword
or to the person that's carrying it I
don't think they released this clip just
because the sword looks cool I think
this is an actual teaser and possible
hint that something significant is going
to happen revolving around this sword do
you guys think there is a chance that
bran could die next season you guys
already know what I want to happen I
want to see the Starks get their steel
back one way or another do you think
there is a chance that bran could give
the sword to Sansa comment below and
tell me what you think about this clip
does it mean anything to you let me know
either way I'm happy as hell to get some
footage even though it's only a few
seconds it still gets me excited about
the show and it has me very curious and
wondering why they actually showed this
I think it really does mean something I
think something's going to happen to
this sword or maybe even Brienne but let
me know but let's move on to the photos
though and I want to give a quick shout
out the cows [ __ ] chickens he's a
game of Thrones youtuber as well and he
actually got the inside scoop on these
photos and was able to release them on
his channel before anyone else had them
which is pretty damn cool so if you want
to see the first video about these new
photos head over to his channel after
you watch this video and I also want to
let you know that I'm going to be
recording with Kyle - we're going to be
making a jaime and cersei video from my
channel then we're going to make a
Sandor and tormund video for his channel
so definitely look out for those but
anyways let's sink our teeth into these
photos now this first photo has me
really excited it appears to be your own
ship silence the ship almost looks like
a character in itself and I'm glad they
did give his ship some personality and
made it very dark with a cracking like
figure on the front of the ship I think
this looks really cool and it will help
play into Euron's phrase when men see my
sails they pray you're on and his ship
strikes fear into the hearts of men and
knowing the kind of man you're on is and
also knowing his ship is crewed by mutes
whose tongues were ripped out would be
terrifying a cell to see if you know
they're coming for you
you're on isn't the type of man to show
any kind of mercy so give me your
thoughts on the style of ship do you
think it looks cool do you think this is
going to help your own become more
intimidating in season seven let me know
what you think about this this next
photo looks to be the unsullied which
are standing in formation right next to
your own ship and if you notice there is
a rather large green screen at the front
of your own ship so this could be taking
place almost anywhere at this point but
it appears that your own will come into
contact with Danny's men which I think
most of us knew what happen already but
there is Lannister men in this
collection of photos too and there is
also a photo of a courtyard which is
more than likely going to be a Casterly
Rock
so does anyone think there was a chance
that urine actually stops at Casterly
Rock first or do you think all these
photos were just taken at different
times casually rock isn't that far from
the iron Island so maybe you're on does
stop there first it's really hard to say
at this point but they could also be in
King's Landing since we do see the
unsullied this could be after Danny
makes it a dragon stone and this could
potentially be Daenerys send in men to
King's Landing to get Yara and the sand
snakes back from your on since we did
see photos of your on parading the girls
through King's Landing do you think
Danny's going to try and get them back I
think she will whether that be by force
or through negotiation I think either
way she's going to send some men to her
own to try to get them back tell me what
you think though but as mentioned before
this photo could potentially be casually
rock and it has me intrigued as well a
good portion of the Lannister forces
should be there but I'm wondering is
there any other reason we will see
Casterly Rock this year do any of you
think Cersei or Jaime is actually going
to leave King's Landing this season to
avoid death I don't really see Cersei
fleeing from the throne but Jaime could
head there for a various number of
reasons and Daenerys could also send men
there to to secure the place that way
Cersei has nowhere to run let me know
what you think about that what will we
see happening actually Rock this season
now this next photo is very interesting
I think this is more than likely going
to be the white that Jon and company
capture north of the wall now of course
this could just be a close-up of one
white like maybe there is more than just
one but they're all out of
frame but my gut tells me this may be
the white that they actually capture and
take to the dragon pit scene
I know people really do hate this idea
but I'm still excited about it
regardless and this photo is interesting
too it looks to be a good bit of
wildlings with a few nice watch members
there too I can see a few different men
in the crowd that are dressed in all
black and I have a pretty good feeling
this may be at the wall or possibly even
right on the northern side of the wall
which could play into the other photo of
the single light but I'm wondering what
everyone's doing here since winter is
here snow is going to be covering almost
everywhere up north so this could
technically be a number of places but I
think this may be near
eastwatch-by-the-sea or just north of
the wall or it might even be north of
Castle black but let me know where you
think this is and tell me what you think
these people are doing I'm very curious
to see what you have to say about this I
haven't really had a whole lot of time
to analyze all these photos and dissect
them because I'm really in the process
of making a bunch of other videos right
now but I just wanted to put these up
and give my initial thoughts on this and
see what you guys had to say about these
two so definitely let me know what you
think about each of these photos but I
think John may have sent men to protect
the wall while he goes south to broker a
deal with Daenerys John knows what is
coming and he also knows the wall was
short on men so he's more than likely
going to send as much help as he can at
least until we can get the other Lords
to chip in and help this could also be
the group of men that torment could
travel with each watch by the sea this
photo has me very intrigued so many
different things can be going on here
but there's one more photo I want to
show you guys apparently this is going
to be one of the bedrooms at Winterfell
more than likely arias bedroom and
according to the source we may even see
a scene in this bedroom with Arya and
Sansa talking about Littlefinger and if
that's true then the part of the leak
may come true as well which is when
Sansa sentences Littlefinger to death
which Arya then carries out which could
be pretty interesting I'm not sure if I
totally buy that yet but you never
really know the show writers may
actually take that pass but either way
Littlefinger is more than likely going
to die next season one way or another so
comment below and give me your thoughts
on all these new spoilers I think
there's some pretty interesting stuff in
here and I'm curious to see what you
have to say about it all maybe you're
seeing some
that I don't and if you do please let me
know thanks for watching everybody and I
will see you all down in the comment
section bye